had no idea - Lia was good walking on
stage - 2,200 people at the celebrity
theater it's a round theatre so you're
surrounded by everybody and I just hear
them after 15 minutes into my act I just
hear I don't know dude I don't think so
I don't think Adam I don't even like
this whole situation I'm like what the
[ __ ] no idea he takes I had no idea he
walks out of the show here Thursday he
takes down Thursday Thursday night Brian
chose it frank caliendo's no it's
Brian's because do you think you'd care
by coming your [ __ ] now love it he goes
I guess he goes now let me for those of
you who don't know who I am
hahahaha
I'm Chris D'Elia oh my god he goes now I
played not this theater than one I
played a lot bigger but it doesn't
matter so that's why so here's the thing
he was [ __ ] ro suz I'll save it and
I'll say this I think crystal is
performance on last Thursday's podcast
is the funniest guest appearance we have
ever had okay you were laughing you your
chin was in here you were like laughing
how often do we laugh like that you were
just dying
you just whoa dude I know I gotta be yes
the year a hundred percent
nightly I mean 100% how do you how do
you compete with that who wants to
compete with that
he was in he was on on like rating on on
on on a text and I said you make me want
to stop doing stand-up comedy secretly
super disciplined oh never Glade uh
Chris is never late he's never will show
up every day he does stand-up every
single day
yeah you know what he meant jiu-jitsu he
showed up there he goes I was there
every single day for three hours and I
never got good because it wasn't his
thing but he's so [ __ ] funny man
look at him with his sunglasses I knew
he's gonna do that so I wore mine till
God he's funny
yeah to me that's the best performance
on firing the camera degree I had so
many people tell me that it was so
[ __ ] funny I know it was so funny man
and he kept turning to me
oh you it my bad yeah how about with
your brother is like move your legs
please move your lashes all tight stiff
J was sitting bolt upright I know right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]